CAn : Dans quelle mesure ce qu'il s'est produit
n'est-il qu'une conséquence indésirable ?
Les médias traditionnels où vous avez travaillé
avaient ce rôle d'organisation et de médiation
où des normes étaient observées,
des histoires étaient rejetées car elles n'étaient pas crédibles,
mais maintenant que le standard de publication et d'amplification
n'est que l'intérêt, l'attention, l'excitation, les clics --
« Ai-je eu des clics ? »
« Envoie ça ! » --
cela a-t-il en partie causé le problème ?
CAm : C'est un gros problème, nous l'avons vu pour les élections de 2016
où l'idée du « piège à clics » était très attractive
alors tous ces sites de fake news et toutes ces fausses informations
n'étaient pas mis en ligne aléatoirement et par hasard,
il y a eu toute une industrie de création de fake news
dans certaines parties de l'Europe de l'Est
et c'est semé dans l'espace et dans le cyberespace.
Je crois également
que la capacité de notre technologie à proliférer ces choses
à la vitesse du son ou de la lumière, à propos --
nous n'avons jamais connu cela avant.
Nous n'avons jamais fait face à un volume si massif d'informations
qui ne sont pas organisées
par des gens dont la profession les mènent à se conformer à la vérité,
à vérifier les faits
et à maintenir un code de conduite et un code d'éthique professionnelle.
CAn : Beaucoup de gens ici connaissent des gens travaillant à Facebook,
à Twitter, à Google et ainsi de suite.
Ils ont l'air d'être des gens géniaux avec de bonnes intentions --
supposons cela.
Si vous pouviez parler aux dirigeants de ces entreprises,
que leur diriez-vous ?
CAm : Vous savez quoi --
ils ont certainement de très bonnes intentions,
ils ont développé un système incroyable et révolutionnaire
où tout le monde est connecté sur ce truc appelé Facebook.
Ils se sont créé une économie énorme
et des revenus énormes.
Je dirais simplement :
« Il est temps de se réveiller, de sentir l'odeur de café
et de regarder ce qu'il nous arrive. »
Mark Zuckerberg veut créer une communauté mondiale.
Je veux savoir : à quoi va ressembler cette communauté mondiale ?
Je veux savoir où sont les codes de conduite.
Mark Zuckerberg a dit --
et je ne le lui reproche pas, il le croyait probablement --
qu'il était fou de penser
que les Russes ou quiconque puisse trifouiller et créer la confusion
sur cette avenue.
Qu'avons-nous appris au cours des dernières semaines ?
Il y a eu un problème majeur à ce propos
et maintenant ils doivent enquêter et comprendre.
Maintenant, ils essayent de faire ce qu'ils peuvent
pour éviter la montée des fake news
mais, vous savez,
cela a été assez libre pendant très longtemps.
Je crois que je dirais :
« Vous êtes géniaux en termes de technologie,
trouvez un autre algorithme.
N'est-ce pas possible ? »
CAn : Qui inclut l'investigation journalistique --
CAm : Je ne sais pas vraiment comment ils font, mais d'une façon,
filtrer les conneries !
(Rires)
Pas seulement ce qui est involontaire --
(Applaudissements)
mais les mensonges délibérés qui sont insérés
par des gens qui font ceci dans un cadre de guerre
depuis des décennies.
Les Soviétiques, les Russes --
ils sont les maîtres de la guerre via d'autres moyens, la guerre hybride.
C'est un --
c'est ce qu'ils ont décidé de faire.
Cela a fonctionné aux États-Unis,
cela n'a pas fonctionné en France ni en Allemagne.
Durant les élections là-bas, où ils ont essayé d'interférer,
l'actuel président français, Emmanuel Macron,
a pris une position ferme, a confronté cela directement,
Angela Merkel également.
CAn : Il y a de l'espoir à ce sujet, n'est-ce pas ?
Que le monde apprend.
Nous avons été dupés une fois, peut-être deux,
mais peut-être pas trois.
Est-ce vrai ?
CAm : Espérons-le.
Mais je pense que tant de choses sont liées à la technologie,
que l'on doit donner à la technologie une conscience morale.
Je dis n'importe quoi, mais vous savez ce que je veux dire.
CAn : Il nous faut un algorithme filtrant les conneries et avec une conscience --
CAm : Exactement.
CAn : Cela semble bien.
CAm : Une « technologie morale ».
Nous avons tous une conscience morale -- une technologie morale.
CAn : C'est un défi important. CAm : Vous me comprenez.
CAn : Parlez une minute de leadership.
Vous avez eu la chance de parler à tant de gens à travers le monde.
Certains d'entre nous --
je parle pour moi, j'ignore si les autres partagent cela --
il y a une déception :
où sont les dirigeants ?
Nombre d'entre nous ont été déçus --
Aung San Suu Kyi, les événements récents,
c'est « une autre qui mord la poussière ».
C'est déchirant.
(Rires)
Qui avez-vous rencontré,
qui vous a impressionnée, inspirée ?
CAm : Vous parlez du monde en crise,
ce qui est tout à fait vrai,
et ceux d'entre nous qui passent leur vie immergés dans la crise --
nous sommes tous au bord de la dépression nerveuse.
C'est assez stressant actuellement.
Vous avez raison --
il y a ce vide perçu et réel en terme de leadership,
ce n'est pas moi qui le dis, je questionne tous --
à tous ceux à qui je parle, je parle de leadership.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai parlé à la présidente extravertie du Liberia,
Ellen Johnson Sirleaf,
qui --
(Applaudissements)
dans trois semaines,
elle fera partie des rares dirigeants d'un pays africain
qui se conforment à la constitution
et abandonnent le pouvoir à la fin de leur mandat.
Elle a dit qu'elle voulait le faire pour que ça serve de leçon.
Quand je l'ai questionnée sur le leadership,
j'ai rapidement donné quelques noms,
je lui ai offert le nom du nouveau président français,
Emmanuel Macron.
Elle a dit --
j'ai dit : « Que pensez-vous quand je dis son nom ? »
Elle a dit :
« Il s'annonce comme étant potentiellement
un dirigeant qui va combler notre vide actuel en terme de leadership. »
J'ai trouvé cela très intéressant.
Hier, je l'ai interviewé.
Je suis très fière d'avoir eu sa première interview internationale.
J'ai été très impressionnée.
J'ignore si je devrais dire cela lors d'une discussion ouverte,
mais j'ai été très impressionnée.
(Rires)
Ce peut être parce que c'était sa première interview
mais, j'ai posé des questions et devinez quoi !
Il a répondu !
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Il n'y a pas eu de pirouette,
pas de manœuvres,
pas de discours de cinq minutes pour en arriver au sujet.
Je n'ai pas eu à l'interrompre,
ce pour quoi je suis devenue célèbre,
car je veux que les gens répondent à la question.
Il m'a répondu
et c'était plutôt intéressant.
Il a dit --
CAn : Dites-moi ce qu'il a dit.
CAm : Non, allez-y.
CAn : Vous interrompez, moi, j'écoute.
CAn : Qu'a-t-il dit ?
CAm : Vous avez parlé de nationalisme et de tribalisme.
Je lui ai demandé : « Comment avez-vous eu le courage
d'affronter les vents dominants
de l'anti-mondialisation, du nationalisme, du populisme
avec ce qui arrive avec le Brexit,
avec ce qui est arrivé aux États-Unis
et aurait pu arriver dans beaucoup d'élection européennes
début 2017 ? »
Il a dit :
« Pour moi, le nationalisme, c'est la guerre.
Nous l'avons vu auparavant,
nous l'avons déjà vécu sur mon continent
et je suis très clair à ce sujet. »
Il n'allait pas, simplement pour l'opportunisme politique,
embrasser le dénominateur commun le plus bas
qui avait été embrassé dans d'autres élections politiques.
Il a fait face à Marine Le Pen, qui est une femme très dangereuse.
CAn : Dernière question pour vous.
Parlez-nous d'une idée à partager.
Si vous pouviez semer une idée dans l'esprit de tous les gens présents,
quelle serait-elle ?
CAm : Soyez très vigilants quant à où vous tirez vos informations ;
soyez responsables de ce que vous lisez, écoutez et regardez ;
assurez-vous d'obtenir vos informations d'enseignes de confiance,
peu importe si votre consommation d'informations est vaste et éclectique,
tenez-vous en aux enseignes que vous connaissez,
car actuellement dans ce monde,
nos crises, nos défis, nos problèmes sont si graves
qu'à moins de tous nous impliquer en tant que citoyens du monde
qui apprécient la vérité,
qui comprennent la science, les preuves empiriques et les faits,
nous allons simplement suivre le chemin
vers une catastrophe potentielle.
Je dirais la vérité
et, pour revenir à Emmanuel Macron,
parler d'amour.
Il n'y a pas assez d'amour.
Je lui ai demandé de me parler d'amour.
Je lui ai dit : « Votre mariage est le sujet d'une obsession mondiale. »
(Rires)
« Parlez-moi d'amour. Qu'est-ce que c'est pour vous ? »
Je n'ai jamais parlé d'amour à un président ou un dirigeant élu.
J'ai essayé.
Il a dit -- il a vraiment répondu.
Il a dit : « J'aime ma femme.
Elle fait partie de moi, nous sommes ensemble depuis des décennies. »
Mais voici ce qui compte vraiment,
ce qui m'a frappée.
Il a dit :
« C'est si important pour moi d'avoir quelqu'un à la maison
qui me dit la vérité. »
J'ai rapporté ça chez moi. Tout est question de vérité.
(Rires)
CAn : Voilà. Vérité et amour. Des idées à partager.
Christiane Amanpour, merci beaucoup. C'était génial.
(Applaudissements)
CAm : Merci. CAn : C'était très agréable.
CAm : Merci.